[Music]
welcome back to science clique today
what would we see if we fell into a
black hole
a black hole is a spherical region of
the universe a sort of space-time bubble
which has an intense gravity
this bubble attracts objects as if it
were pulling the fabric of space
not unlike a star or a planet
the surface of the bubble is called the
horizon of the black hole it divides the
universe into two regions the exterior
and the interior
below the horizon the fabric of the
universe is pulled so quickly that
nothing not even light can escape
today we know that our universe contains
many black holes they are very distant
and represent no danger to us
nonetheless we can wander out of
curiosity what we might see if we were
to fall into one of them
answering this will allow us to improve
our understanding of the extreme
phenomena of our universe and to rectify
a few common misconceptions on the
subject
our galaxy the milky way hosts in its
core a supermassive black hole called
sagittarius a star
using a spaceship we approach it at a
reasonable distance
and we jump into the void of space
here begins our fall
it will last about one hour and will be
fatal to us
the spaceship remains stationed orbiting
the black hole and witnessing our fall
[Music]
before we even start falling we run into
a problem
the black hole is supermassive its
gravity equates to a mass millions of
times greater than the sun
with such an attraction it captures
stars and surrounding mata forming a
thick disk of plasma that orbits around
it
[Music]
this disc spins incredibly fast almost
at light speed and loses energy by
friction causing turbulences that heat
it up
it thus produces intense radiations
light ultraviolets x-rays and gamma rays
which blind us instantly and risk
burning us alive
[Music]
the plasma itself which can reach
several billion degrees might also well
burn us alive
in what follows we will therefore assume
that we are equipped with an extremely
resistant spacesuit which allows us to
withstand the heat and filter out any
harmful radiation
[Music]
however despite the spacesuit the disc
still seems extremely bright we can't
distinguish anything
we will therefore imagine that our
helmet has a visor which helps reduce
the brightness of the disc so that we
can observe it in detail as well as see
the stars in the background
[Music]
at first we notice that the disc is blue
within the whole electromagnetic
spectrum produced our visor filters
everything but visible light the light
our eyes can see
in this spectrum the disc emits more
blue because this colour is more
energetic
it is the same effect that gives very
hot stars a bluish tint
strangely one side of the disk looks
brighter than the other
to understand the matter orbits very
quickly such that on one side it
approaches us at high speed while on the
other side it moves away
on one side the light waves get stacked
together we receive them with greater
frequency while on the other side the
light gets stretched we receive it with
less energy
this is called the doppler effect
it's the same phenomenon that occurs
with sound waves when a car crosses the
street
looking at the black hole we see that
the back of the disc appears warped as
if it were folded around the horizon
forming a ring of light
this is due to the strong gravity of the
black hole which deflects light rays
acting like a gravitational lens
looking in one direction we observe
objects that are actually located
elsewhere
[Music]
finally the stars in the background seem
ever so slightly blue
we do not feel it but the black hole
distorts time such that our clock turns
slightly slower than that of distant
stars
compared to our clock the light from the
stars seems accelerated to the extent
that we see it bluer than its original
colour
[Music]
surprisingly during the first 10 minutes
of the fall the black hole appears to be
moving away
we are moving closer and closer to it
but its image seems to shrink more and
more
imagine throwing a bull through a car
the ball is thrown at 90 degrees and
crosses the car side to side
the passenger sees the ball travel
across the car at 90 degrees
but imagine now that the car is moving
this time the passenger sees the ball
coming from the front with a narrow
angle
because the car is moving objects
reaching it seem to come from a
different direction
more from the front
[Music]
in our case the situation is analogous
only with light rays instead of a ball
we receive the light of the disc from a
certain direction but because we are
moving towards the black hole the rays
seem to reach us from a different
direction squashed towards the front
this is called aberration
[Music]
after these first ten minutes we are now
falling very quickly at four percent the
speed of light
and from this point onwards the black
hole starts to grow in our field of view
[Music]
as minutes go by we gradually descend
towards the black hole
our speed increases and we receive the
light in front of us with an
increasingly high intensity while the
light behind us seems to get darker
[Music]
this again is the doppler effect at play
when falling towards the black hole we
catch up with the light in front of us
while the light behind us has more
difficulty reaching us
[Music]
if we turned around we would notice that
the clock inside the spaceship seems to
be running slower than before
the effect is subtle but still
noticeable
this is also due to the doppler effect
if we imagine that the clock emits a
signal each second these signals take
longer and longer to reach us and we
thus observe the ticking in slow motion
[Music]
minutes pass
and we gradually fly over the disk of
matter
suddenly after 57 minutes of falling the
disc seems to fade out
we have just reached the point beyond
which mata can no longer orbit the black
hole steadily
the gravity is so intense that at this
distance the plasma begins to spiral
very quickly into the black hole
things will now get much faster
[Music]
just two minutes later we are twice as
close to the horizon
from now on any light coming from
outside is destined to fall into the
black hole
this is called the photon sphere
at this precise distance it's even
possible for light to orbit the black
hole
[Music]
as we approach more and more the
passengers who remained in the spaceship
see our image fade and gradually slow
down until freezing on the horizon
the light that we emit takes more and
more time to escape the black hole it is
received increasingly slowly and
gradually fades away
the passengers will never see us cross
the horizon
but for us just 24 seconds after
crossing the photon sphere it is time to
reach the horizon
after this moment it will be impossible
for us to go back
but what do we see when crossing the
horizon
surprisingly enough nothing special
it would in fact be very difficult to
determine when exactly we crossed the
horizon
[Music]
we still receive the light of distant
stars which falls with us
[Music]
we can still see the spaceship in orbit
in which the clock even if it seems
slowed down is still ticking
and we can still perfectly see our body
and in particular our feet
because even if all light is carried
inwards
it can still move upwards relative to us
and thus reach our eyes
this is actually a fundamental principle
on a global scale space time is curved
by the black hole and generates this
horizon inside which objects are
disconnected from the outside
but at the local scale space time is
almost flat and the curvature is not
noticeable which means that everything
behaves normally
[Music]
furthermore as opposed to what one might
think the image of the black hole does
not appear to encompass us at all
even if we are now inside the black hole
its image only takes up 15 percent of
our field of view
the rest is still filled with stars
this is again due to the phenomenon of
aberration
now that we move extremely fast the
light that arrives from the sides and
even from behind seems to come from the
front
our field of view is contracted ahead of
us
and widened behind us
in particular the spaceship behind us
seems to grow larger even though we move
away from it
we have crossed the horizon and nothing
special has happened
however from now on if we try to send a
signal to the outside it will never
reach its destination
below the horizon everything is destined
to fall downwards with no hope of ever
coming out
but for the moment everything is fine
it is after another 30 seconds just
before reaching the center of the black
hole that in the blink of an eye we feel
an incredibly powerful force that
stretches us until dislocating our body
this is called spaghettification
our head being further from the center
than our feet the difference in pull is
such that our body is very quickly torn
apart
[Music]
in our very last moments we have the
impression of falling onto a flat
surface as if we were reaching the
surface of an entirely black planet
while a circle of light intensifies all
around us
a tenth of a second later the shredded
remains of our body reached the center
of the black hole
our journey ends here for the moment
modern physics cannot describe what
happens this close to the center of a
black hole
our current theories describe
singularities points where the curvature
of space-time becomes infinite but
scientists suspect that these
singularities do not really exist we
would have to unify gravity with quantum
physics if we wish to understand these
extreme regions of the cosmos
for now some hypotheses even question
the fact that one could survive crossing
the horizon
moreover in reality black holes can have
an angular momentum which generates
strange effects with multiple horizons
and mathematical instabilities whose
consequences we do not yet understand
that said our current theory still give
us a good idea of what we would see
in particular we can correct a few
widespread misconceptions
for example the disc around the black
hole is not orange but blue
if some images show it as orange this is
because they use false colours which are
only intended to represent luminosity
but not the real colour in visible light
another idea that is widespread is that
we would observe the whole history of
the universe unfold before our eyes
while our field of view would get
engulfed by the black hole
this is also wrong as it forgets to take
into account the doppler effect and the
aberration of light
there are however many mysteries left to
solve and we will have to wait until our
theories are perfected to understand
what truly happens at the heart of a
real black hole
[Music]
[Music]
you